-I'm very excited about this.
I have a new holiday song
I'm releasing,
with me and Dolly Parton,
called "Almost Too Early
for Christmas."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's out Friday, November 4th.
And. so, I talked
about this last night,
I put it on TikTok
with the song
and say it's out on Friday.
And TikTok took it down.
It's illegal.
-What -- Because --
-Because it's not out yet?
-They said --
Yeah, because it's not out.
They said they couldn't
get the rights to...
So now I'm in a lawsuit
with myself.
-Oh, my --
You're suing yourself?
-I'm suing myself. And I'm not
returning my phone calls.
-Really?!
-I'm gonna let me
sweat it out a little bit.
-Oh, wow. Acrimonious.
-Yeah, 'cause I don't know
if I'm ready -- Really?
What, am I gonna listen to me,
make decisions about my music?
-No. F that. F that noise.
-So I don't --
It's a great song.
I can't wait
for people to hear it,
but I guess
it actually is too early.
[ Laughter ]
TikTok told me it actually
is too early for Christmas.
The point of the story is,
if you want to --
if you like it, if you want
to retweet it, you can't.
Not until Friday.
-Friday.
-Friday it's out.
Thank you, Dolly.
And I'm sorry, me.